good morning said Bilbo and he meant it
what do you mean
Gandalf said do you wish me a good
morning or mean that it is a good
morning whether I want it or not or that
you feel good this morning or that it is
a morning to be good on all of them at
once said Boober what a lot of things
you do use good morning for said Gandalf
what Gandalf is stubbornly ignoring in
that conversation because there is no
way that a wizard who has lived in
middle-earth for three thousand years
doesn't understand good morning but and
what he is stubbornly ignoring is that
the phrase good morning doesn't usually
convey information at all instead it
serves a social function it is a
greeting expressions like this are
called Phatak expressions they are
phrases where the semantic information
is much less important than the
pragmatic information and generally it's
to do with politeness how are you how's
it going and hello are all phrases that
are made of different words but mean
approximately the same thing to the
point you can switch them up fairly
interchangeably as long as they're
totally appropriate and you're used to
them if you are an American in Britain
it might be quite jarring to be asked
you are right as a greeting for many
North Americans are you all right is not
a Phatak expression so are you all right
expresses a genuine concern also it
probably won't be your right it'll just
be yeah I the other way around
applies to what's up for most Britons is
an expression of concern not a greeting
it's not Phatak in British English
Phatak expressions change with time how
do you do
erodes over time to howdy-do and then
howdy but all of those sound dated and
formal to most modern listeners and
these changes happen all the time it's
now usual to reply to thank you with no
problem but that's a bit contentious
because for some usually older folks no
problem is not Phatak and it's impolite
it should be you're welcome instead
which too many younger folks also sounds
impolite we're going to have these
generational differences as long as
language continues to change so why do
we bother with fatica expressions at all
why is it rude to just immediate
jump to what you actually want to say
well greetings are a way to either
acknowledge another person to to
initiate conversation by establishing a
relationship or their a verbal sort of
handshake to make sure that everyone is
paying attention
depending on the fatica expression that
we choose we can convey a hierarchical
relations or intent we can use them for
saying goodbye
there are also fatica expressions of all
back-channeling which is how we express
that we are actively listening those
serve the pragmatic function of
demonstrating that yes you are listening
and that you don't desire to be the one
talking at the moment you're not going
to interrupt this is why back channels
often happen at the end of sentences
they are the listener recognizing that
they could jump into the conversation at
this point but they are choosing to
continue to listen instead their
trevelin Sperrys from language to
language and culture to culture which
can lead to misunderstandings in
japanese back-channeling is so
ubiquitous that foreign business people
sometimes mistake it for agreement and
think that people are saying ok I agree
and not ok I understand you carry on not
all Phatak expressions are treated
equally by everyone so look out for them
they are everywhere play around with
them and use unusual ones if you want
just don't be Gandalf my co-author
Gretchen McCulloch snoo book because
Internet includes a bit on why we stress
out so much about Phatak expressions in
email whether you should start that
message with high or dear name or
something else entirely there are links
to her book in the description